breaking first at four shooting
investigation at western high school
involving both ccsd police and metro
it's happening now near bonanza and
decatur good afternoon thank you for
joining us at four i'm kirsten joyce and
i'm christian casadis let's get right
out to madison kimbrough who is live at
the scene in madison what's the update
yeah so it's a very active scene out
here a lot of commotion's going on as
you can see metro police as well as ccsd
police crime tape blocking off the area
what we know so far is that ccsdpd is
investigating an incident at western
high school you know we've talked to
some parents we also talked to a student
as we approached the area we saw several
students walking home one of which told
us this is unconfirmed that the reason
for the police activity is because a
student brought a gun to school another
student we spoke to said they heard
gunshots we're still waiting on details
from ccsd pd and metro make sure to stay
with 8 news now for the latest details
reporting live near western high school
madison kimbrough live local now